Suraj Suraj rush rush rush rush rush
Suraj Raval guys this kind of sucks I
don't want to make this video I'm
actually serious I like Suraj for fall
and I've liked his videos I've enjoyed
some of his videos in the past if you
don't know he's a machine-learning guy
hello world it's Suraj and it's not just
a couple of industries that machine
learning is affecting it's every single
industry but he stepped into the fake
guru house when he made a two hundred
dollar course that mislead people which
we will get into in a second so
unfortunately I cannot just because I
like somebody not do a video on him when
I'm trying to educate consumers about
future choices so unfortunately I have
to do this video let me say first that
as someone in the educational space
who's made an oopsie before I get it
okay and and kind of have a first-hand
understanding of people making mistakes
you know learning from it growing from
it but there have been some people
alleging that in Suraj's case this is
not a one-off problem this is not a
one-time oopsie this is sort of a
pattern of behavior I've made a severe
and continuous that I will leave up to
you guys I am just going to cover the
facts of the case and we're gonna talk
about some of the larger problems that
people have brought up this is with the
intent of educating you because this is
not Suraj's first course so I cannot
just let this go because there's
probably going to be a course in the
future and when there is and when
there's another Siraj Raval course I
want you to be educated without further
ado let's jump into it here's the course
that Suraj revolve pitched so I've
decided to make the highest value course
I possibly could call make money with
machine learning now there's a lot here
that's sort of a problem but the biggest
thing is he says that he was going to
limit his course to 500 students in
order to give them personalized
instruction and I'm only accepting 500
students so that I can give each of them
personalized education and guidance and
everything was going fine until people
started to notice there were messages
going on there were works
that didn't make sense so people did a
little digging around and they found out
and by the way this is a registrar
article which kind of sums up the whole
situation in better detail than I will
they found out that there were two
separate workspaces that Siraj had set
up one of them had 770 students one of
them had 500 students and essentially
Suraj had been duplicitous about his
stopping the course at 500 students
because he was gonna keep it all
personal and whatever and give them
personalized instruction and I'm we
accepting 500 students and he got a
little well got a little greedy he
decided to keep letting people in the
course and when he did he tried to
basically lie about it and keep it from
everyone from knowing by creating two
separate slack groups that didn't have
any idea of their the other person's
existence long story short everyone
finds out everyone gets pretty upset and
they start realizing that Suraj is not
giving the personalized experience that
a lot of them are wanting so at this
point people are pretty pissed off and
they start to look around and maybe say
okay well we kind of need a refund and
this is kind of where it goes south okay
so the first thing that happens is
everyone gets moved to discord because
allegedly Suraj didn't want to pay for
the slack like fee of setting up a
professional slack so once he got to the
message limit he moved everyone over to
discord a--when he did people started
mentioning the word refund for a lot of
reasons because a lot of them said you
know the course wasn't up to expectation
etc etc when that started happening
people who were mentioning refund in the
comments started to get their message
deleted automatically and some of them
were saying they were getting banned
again this is all in this registrar
report and finally the cries for refunds
got to like a fever pitch and so Suraj
couldn't ignore them anymore and so at
this point Suraj actually mentions that
in fact there was a refund policy that
no one had heard about he ignored us
until it blew up last weekend one
student said in the midst of all this he
snuck up up a refund policy saying the
refund had to be asked within 14 days of
registration and pretended that it was
all there all along which is ludicrous
because there was no
fun policy initially and the policy was
posted four weeks after the registration
start date so what does that mean that
means that he puts he puts the start of
registration four weeks ago and then at
four weeks later he goes oh well you
guys should have taken advantage of the
14-day refund policy and everyone goes
wait there was no refund policy
he added it after the fact according to
like the page history of where you put
the refund policy and I don't know if he
intentionally made it in a time frame
where people were literally couldn't get
refunds at that point but it seems like
he did and at one point Suresh in an
email to somebody who says hey since
we're more than halfway for the course
the refund policy is now ended however
I'd like to give you a special discount
code up to a hundred percent off my next
three courses as if that's gonna make
people happy it's that that's ridiculous
so eventually everyone's getting even
more pissed off because they're like
wait you didn't give us a refund policy
and wait you know this is this is all
made up and in fact if you do not
provide a refund policy at the time of
someone buying your thing there's an
automatic 30-day refund policy so when
finally Suraj gets called out to the
point where he can absolutely no longer
ignore it and after he's tried to
basically get people to accept no refund
and only accept like you know future
courses which is kind of a lame thing if
you just spent $200 and of course you
hate why would you want more of Suraj's
courses so finally he makes this
statement on Twitter and he goes I saw
some dota there unsatisfied I'd like to
apologize I'm gonna send refunds to the
students who asked with it one within 30
days of purchase and a lot of people
just saw this is a very last-minute sort
of cop-out because he had done
everything he could up to that point to
not let people get refunds so that's
where a lot of the stopped and for me
that was like okay maybe that's maybe it
was somebody who just did not have an
experience with a course and maybe you
know this is just a one-off kind of
thing but then bigger alligator I mean
in my opinion bigger allegations started
coming out about Suraj specifically with
Udacity so apparently I didn't I didn't
know this Suraj had a
a course with Udacity and at the meeting
they had to have an intervention with
him because he was basically stealing
people's code for for his sessions so
one of the things that the registrar
accuses him of is basically stealing
people's github code which is kind of a
big deal and something that Suraj very
strongly says that he doesn't do
Suraj says that he actually credited the
author every time in the associated
github reap read me show me a
counterexample which is at this point I
mean this is just what a what a show the
guys from Udacity come in and they
basically slam dunk him they go oh no
not with working with us we literally
had an intervention meeting involving
multiple directors including myself to
explain to you how non-action was bad
even the director of video production
was involved it was so blatant that
non-tech had to point it out so this so
this is pretty serious stuff because
this is another course that he's getting
accused of this with and it's anyway
it's just really unfortunate it sucks it
really does suck but I started to do
some digging and it does not seem to be
an isolated case it doesn't seem to be
just with Udacity it doesn't just seem
to be with this course where shady stuff
is going on Suraj has claimed that he
credits authors is misleading at best so
I want to demonstrate one of those cases
for you right now of how Suraj does not
properly credit people who he takes code
from and he's done that he does this a
lot
I mean basically all nearly all of his
videos are in some way basically most of
the code is taken from other people with
very minimal changes so I'm just gonna
show you an example of that so this is
Suraj's video watch me build a training
bot okay so let's just start this video
first of all watch me build a trading
bot what does that imply it implies okay
I built this thing I mean very clearly I
watch as I build you would think based
on everything here that he's building
this thing in Suraj and I've built an
automated trading
but I built an automated trading bot
right I built I did it it was me
I built the automated trading bot this
video I'm gonna show you how I built it
how I built it how I bet you know I
built it okay here's the thing when you
actually go to code for this video first
of all it takes you to his github page
right
this is his github page it's kind of a
long story but the normal way you're
supposed to do it is they're supposed to
Fork and not just clone to an your own
rip repo with no git history but anyway
that's a long story if you go to his
starter code and then scroll all the way
to the bottom
this is Suraj's idea of credit credits
credits go to ask Mike for the starter
code I have no idea how much credit
actually Mike did because this says
starter code right Suraj built it how I
built it maybe he just built a little
bit off of Mike's starter code okay
let's go check that out
so what a friend of mine who's way
smarter than me did was he helped me do
this like merge thing where we got the
original github code ask Mike's github
code and then we got Suraj's github code
which Suraj does not fork or fork from
ask Mike so I asked Mike probably has no
idea that this guy has basically taken
his code it's that's kind of a long
story I'll let someone who's like more
computer science he explained why that's
kind of bad basically he's taking credit
without real attribution except in like
name only but basically this is the
difference between the two github pages
right and here's that here here's the
headline okay every time it's there's
this arrow like this this is something
that actually gets taken out and anytime
there's an error like this it gets put
into the code this these are the only
differences this is out this is in put
back into the code so basically he just
changes the readme that's all he did he
changes the readme he deletes the guys
read me he takes all the guys code the
starter code is all the code and he
takes the guys readme deletes all the
guys readme and puts in his own thing
and then he goes oh yeah this is the
code for this video by Siraj called
watch me build a training bot and then
he deletes all the other guys
and at the very bottom makes this tiny
thing and go see oh yeah the guy gave me
starter code no he gave you all the code
he gave you all the code this is not
this is not attribution saying saying
somebody gave me a starter script and
it's the whole script is not attribution
saying someone gave starter code not
forking cloning your own repo deleting
the get history so no one can see what's
going on delete the original author
can't see that you link them can't see
that you took their code and then just
crediting with starter code at the
bottom of a second footnoted page from
your original video that you call watch
me build a training bot how I built it
genuinely genuinely I like the guy or I
like the guy style of teaching I think
he's a good educator but this this kind
of behaviour just like it's anyway it's
pretty bad it's pretty bad but I'm not
trying to like dunk on the guy here but
I but I am trying to as in as like a
consumer alert thing just be aware of
this kind of thing and it's just a
consistent pattern of behavior
I mean Suraj you know he might be
excused if he could reasonably claim
that he doesn't know how to use github
because his github practices are kind of
frowned upon but he literally makes a
video called how to use github where he
explains where explains how to fork how
to fork things how to fork things but he
doesn't do it and eventually we maybe
find the reason why github is a social
network and you can follow other
developers to keep up to date with their
latest code the more developers that
follow you the more likely developers
will contribute to your open-source
project currently linus torvalds is the
most followed developer out of 28
million on github and right now I'm
number 15 so watch out Linus I said I
think I think I don't know this is a
little bit speculation I think that's
maybe why Suraj uses github the way he
does I think maybe he's chasing I know
Klout is I don't have clouds the right
word but
I not crediting developers properly he's
able to basically gather a following on
github who thinks who reasonably thinks
unless they really do their due
diligence Suraj is the one who made this
thing you would think Suraj Maeda I mean
after all that's starter code starter
code equals changing the readme so yeah
anyway there's a lot more evidence on
here I'll link some stuff below honestly
this is like a very shallow dive into
all this stuff there's this huge reddit
thread about documenting a lot of these
problems and if you just look at our
slash machine learning you find a lot of
people who are disgruntled because Suraj
used their code in a video never credits
them properly and you know there's
anyway there's all these problems so I
think a lot of his problems would be
solved to be credited people properly
and if he didn't try to mislead people
about return policies and how many
students were gonna be in his course
like all of this seems to be of Suraj's
own making when in reality he has a
great platform he's a good educator yeah
I feel like I don't know I don't know
why he's doing this
so that's the video sorry guys sorry
it's not so fun and exciting I am a
little bit I'm a little bummed out but
at the same time I wanted to let you
guys know what's going on in the
community and obviously Suraj walked
into the fake guru house and
unfortunately you can't walk in without
getting a coffee Zilla video made about
you that's just the way it is yeah so
that's it
[Music]
but never to the trust